und mit dem nahostexperte michael lüders
habe ich jetzt die möglichkeit über den
drohnenangriff auf saudi arabien und
dessen auswirkung zu sprechen
herrlich dass die rebellen haben sich
dazu bekannt wie ist denn aktuell ihre
situation im jemen wären sie denn
überhaupt in der lage so einen
effektiven angriff durchzuführen ganz
ohne hilfe zum beispiel vom iran
die rebellen sind dazu in der lage sie
werden vom iran unterstützt aber nicht
so wie man sich das vielleicht hier
vorstellt es gibt schätzungsweise 80 bis
90 militärberater der revolutionsgarden
aus dem iran sowie der libanesischen
hisbollah miliz im yemen die dort die
hose unterrichten in der bedienung von
raketen und drohnen die überwiegend aus
den militärbeständen der jemenitischen
armee stammen die sämtlich von den
muttis überrollt worden sind und diese
armeebestände dabei handelt es sich
überwiegend um amerikanische und
russische waffen vor allem aber um
amerikanische waffen und die raketen die
die houthi-rebellen in den vergangenen
monaten abgeschlossen haben in richtung
saudi arabien als vergeltung vor allem
für die massiven saudischen angriffe auf
den norden des jemen mit tausenden von
toten diese raketen sind in erster linie
amerikanische raketen die von iranischen
oder hisbollah spezialisten so
ausgerichtet werden dass sie ihre ziele
auch treffen umgekehrt unterstützen die
usa und großbritannien mit
milliardengeldern die saudische
kriegsführung im jemen würden die usa
und großbritannien diese unterstützung
saudi arabiens einstellen wäre der krieg
in saudi arabien beziehungsweise um den
jemen sehr schnell beendet die iraner
müssen nur relativ wenig aufwand
betreiben um saudi arabien maximalen
schaden zuzufügen ist es so gesehen in
der tat ein stellvertreterkrieg
allerdings mit sehr ungleichen
möglichkeiten in waffen technischer
hinsicht saudi arabien ist hier wirklich
der goliath waffentechnisch gesehen die
musik sind eher die kleineren kämpfer
sehr entschlossen aber unterstützen wie
tierisch beraten aus dem iran und
ehrenhafte menschen in saudi arabien
seien auch beteiligt gewesen sagen die
hotel rebellen die glaubhaft ist dass
das ist eine anspielung darauf dass es
im osten saudi
jens eine von der sunnitischen
zentralregierung in riad massiv
unterdrückt die schiitische minderheit
gibt und diese minderheit ist mit den
verhältnissen im königreich nicht
einverstanden
radikale elemente könnten durchaus
geneigt gewesen sein den hut die
rebellen hier zur hand zu gehen wer nun
am ende wirklich hinter diesem angriff
steht das können wir heute nicht
wirklich abschließend beurteilen
theoretisch sind die houthi-rebellen
dazu in der lage
aber ob sie es wirklich waren das muss
man abwarten der iran selber wird mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
nicht den startschuss gegeben haben man
kann der politischen führung in teheran
vieles vorwerfen aber gewiss nicht dass
sie dumm wäre in dieser situation einen
solchen angriff zu befehlen oder
dahinter zu stehen
das wäre ja geradezu eine einladung an
die usa israel und saudi arabien in den
iran nannte den iran anzugreifen
die arabischen medien allen voran al
jazira der nachrichtensender mit sitz in
katar berichtet heute von einer anderen
möglichkeit dass nämlich pro-iranische
milizen im irak einen solchen angriff
durchgeführt haben könnten und zwar als
vergeltung dafür dass israel in den
vergangenen wochen wiederholt stellungen
schiitischer milizen in syrien und im
irak darunter auch im süden des iraks
angegriffen habe inwieweit wurde denn
jetzt mit diesem anschlag demonstriert
wie verwundbar der weltweit größte
ölexporteur ist und wichtiger partner
der usa im golf und welche folgen könnte
das jetzt haben ja die frage die sie
stellen ist wirklich eine sehr
wesentliche es ist ja auch sommer sicht
wirklich eine peinlichkeit
sondergleichen
sie müssen sich vorstellen saudi arabien
kauft waffen in den usa ein im
dreistelligen milliardenbereich
und nun ist es insgesamt zehn drohnen
abgefeuert sagen wir mal von den houthi
rebellen im jemen bis wir näheres wissen
ist es also gelungen mit einer
vergleichsweise schlichten technologie
die zudem noch nicht teuer ist in der in
der herstellung beziehungsweise in der
anwendung gelingt es also einen
verheerenden anschlag zu führen auf ein
wichtiges öl terminal- und auf die
einrichtungen saudi arabien wo das öl
raffiniert wird das ist mit sehr wenig
aufwand ein maximaler effekte und das
bedeutet
atex dass die saudische armee nichts
taugt und dass die milliarden
investitionen in amerikanische
waffensysteme ebenfalls nichts nicht
helfen bei der verteidigung saudi
arabiens das wird noch gravierende
folgen haben die golfstaaten werden sich
überlegen ob sie auch weiterhin in so
großem umfang waffen in den usa
einkaufen und es ist ja auch
bemerkenswert dass sich der us-präsident
sofort an die seite saudi arabiens
gestellt hat wir sind bereit vergeltung
zu üben wenn sich denn die spur in
richtung iran bewahrheiten sollte
interessant ist dass die saudische
führung selbst mit schuldzuweisungen
bislang sehr zurückhaltend ist man hat
bislang nicht den iran selber
verantwortlich gemacht sondern man
spricht von iranischen waffen die ihr
verwendet worden sein
eine letzte frage wie wahrscheinlich
halten sie denn eine militärische
eskalation in der derzeitigen situation
ja das ist natürlich schwer zu
beantworten wir hatten in den letzten
wochen immer wieder situationen die sehr
gefährlich waren dann glaubte man dass
sich die lage entspannt habe nach der
entlassung des nationalen
sicherheitsberaters john bolton durch
präsident trump der ein maßgeblicher
scharfmacher war in dieser konfrontation
mit dem iran
und nun diese chance dieser angriff auf
saudi arabien also ich würde mal sagen
es steht wirklich wieder spitz auf knopf
die amerikaner werden sich sehr genau
überlegen wie sie militärisch vergeltung
üben in absprache mit saudi arabien
aber wo diese angriffe dann stattfinden
darüber kann man nur spekulieren es ist
wirklich eine sehr sehr gefährliche sehr
anzunehmen die situation und man kann
nur hoffen dass die politisch
verantwortlichen in washington sehr
genau die folgen ihres tuns abwägen denn
wenn es hier zum krieg kommt gegen den
iran
dann wird von dem moment an eine art
kernschmelze zu beobachten seien in
politischer und militärischer hinsicht
dann kann man die lage in der region
nicht mehr kontrollieren
beunruhigende worte von michael lüders
vielen dank nach berlin